did you know Google is the only cloud
provider that offers second byc video
descriptions with a video to text mode
video description on vertex AI provides
customers with a semantic understanding
of a video in the form of text
generating granular and detailed
descriptions for a video for example you
can generate automated captions for
short form video support accessibility
use cases understand and search
important moments in videos initiate an
alert or workflow based on events
detected in descriptions improve ad
placement Drive deeper video analytics
and catalog and archive Legacy video
content you can even gain deeper
insights into your videos and your users
who consume them like finding out why
people stopped watching at a certain
time and identify moments in the video
that especially resonated with your
users and why